how are you Bart replies with praise
Allah very good brother how are you and
then and then later in the day it took
him six hours to come up with a response
he goes how are you my friend have you
paid attention to today's encryption
Market Muhammad why you talk to me this
way like we are strangers
[Music]
have you guys heard about chat GPT I
like it we like it we love it a guy in
California says I could probably use
this technology to piss off and waste
the time of some telemarketer scum and
that's exactly great applications that's
better application than some of the
other applications I've heard agreed
well how does he do it so check this out
he has a service called Jolly Roger
customers paying like 25 a year to use
this product and the idea is to use like
a voice cloner to keep the scammer on
the line for as long as possible
but does it waste your phone bills your
phone bills your minutes is a waste your
minutes that's a great question I don't
know because what if someone's trying to
call you and then like a scam you're on
the scam call and then you can't pick up
that number what if the scammers using
chat gbg2 and just talking forever maybe
they're just like using Google
Chinese restaurants
well my minutes roll over is the
question as well
thanks Nick and will the AI will the AI
can you check in there I'm checking what
about anything well the AI thing still
give your credit card info
so they have preset expressions and
topic specific responses that are forced
through a voice cloner so the
telemarketer actually thinks they're
talking to a real human being wow like
in one such instance a chat bot named
Whitey whiteboard picked up a call from
a recorded uh female voice with a
warning about a Bank of America
um uh account
and the Whiteboard the chat bot said
something back and the telemarketer call
got transferred to a real person who
then tried to talk to the chat bot about
credit card consolidation whoa
that's the game huh yep and um the guy
who invented this he told the Wall
Street Journal that it sounded like the
caller was fishing for financial
information they could use for identity
theft which is one of the scams that
often happens right and the caller who
who apparently didn't work for Bank of
America only got goofy responses that
drug dragged out the conversation so
it's kind of like that tuber guy yes
who's who [__] with the scammers I love
those videos waste all their time
deletes their files yeah dude so he's a
Savage Dude Looks into their webcams
yeah dude he takes a picture of their
whole call center he calls them by their
first names yeah yeah they're like and
then they all go hacker hacker hacker
and then they all start shutting down
these are scrambling yeah he'll even um
you know he's found like where they are
and then buy it the next week they're
gone yep yep yeah the whole building's
gone like a five-story building gone
that's crazy yeah so um people are I
mean
I think this whole room is pretty much
Petty enough to pay for a service for
these guys I would love to my I get my
phone calls that I get every like I
don't remember the last time I got a
legit phone call from a normal person
honestly Sam I get [__] scam [__]
[__] all the time it always says spam
risk spam risk and it's like I get every
different variation of all the hustles
you pick it up I don't even pick them up
no no the voicemails I believe I just
look at the voicemails and I'm like what
the [__] is this but even on text you
always got Chinese girls so thirsty oh
dude they're so horny though you miss me
there's a new one where it goes hey I
don't know why I have your number in my
phone book like how do I know you like
that's a new one or one was like
you want to get breakfast question mark
and I was like whoa I always right back
at the Middle Eastern uh terrorist yeah
what do you say let me see
no I always I don't know if it saved it
but Ryan what do you do what do you do
when someone texts you and they ask you
to give you a picture give my credit
card info that's smart you know you'll
send a picture of me and bring it on
yeah usually I usually send a picture of
Nick
and I just say how's it going this is me
this is me sleeping and it kind of gets
it kind of makes it obvious that there's
no way that's a real [__] guy what do
you mean so they just stop bothering oh
they're like oh this guy's messing
around God I love no person who looks
like this this is a meme
the way that these guys go from being
like hello I am with Bank of America and
then I'm like
I'm like
and I'm like you're not with Bank of
America dude I think America good boys
don't fly off the handles start calling
me gay bloody [__] you bloody so this is
a text that I got from like a random
number
so the random number goes how are you
Bart replies with praise Allah very good
brother how are you and then and then
later in the day it took him [__] six
hours to come up with a response to to
swipe through all the different uh
responses and have he goes how are you
my friend have you paid attention to
today's encryption Market Muhammad why
you talk to me this way like we are
strangers
[Laughter]
say to this guy
that's so good it's [__]
why you talk to me like this when we are
best buddy
Muhammad you came over it was just such
a thin line for these guys like between
like their decorum on the line and then
just complete vitriol so anger if they
if you pick up a phone call and it's an
actual person on there you'll just
starts being like [__] you I hate you
yeah yeah and they'll flip out every
time
it makes me laugh really hard
I try to do it at least once a week but
yeah I because I just I just like go at
it immediately I'm like you scamming
pieces and [__] and then they're like
[__] you you [__] [__] your
mother and all this [__] I'm like that's
always [__] your mother it's always [__]
your mother oh it's always that I'm gay
and then they want
do you ever say [__] your mother back to
them
uh I would never be that disrespectful
I don't talk about moms nah I keep moms
because it must be it must strike a
quarter with them because if they're
trying to go for blood right away and
they use mothers on you then that means
like that's their soft spot that's their
uh that's their line they go so fast
into it like they're just saying he's
just saying he's with the Microsoft
store
like 10 seconds prior
and he's screaming his head off of the
phone if I want a [__] [__] piece
of [__] dude I want to do this but I
feel like if I were to pick up the phone
call I'd I'd stumble over my words and I
I would start a lot of delivery yeah it
is like a big misconception a lot of
people are like oh some some of these
guys are just like nice people that are
forced into doing this work it's like no
to be honest a lot of them are [__]
pieces of [__] where they're from too
yeah of course and they're ripping off
they're [__] so many people that's
why they while out like that because now
they can [__] talk how they talk
normally you know what I mean like
probably kills them that they have to be
polite [__] your mother I'm telling you
a little hot tip just go right into them
lay it right into them and they leave
you alone for a little bit and also too
like if you record it you might be able
to have a really cool YouTube channel
that's true it is funny how people like
out here think that like all of India
[__] does that it's like India hates
this [__] as much as we do they are also
getting scams
I don't think a local call is cheaper
that's why they have to move the
buildings because they know that Indian
authorities are going to come yeah and
they come in hard they they get pissed
like that hacker that did that he was
watching the webcam when the uh when he
swatted them or when he called the the
authorities and then they he was
watching The Raid go down damn yeah
they're quick man there's one guy he um
he even traced it back to the States
because he was like how are they so you
in the states they they have you like
send like wads of cash in a box
to like a P.O box so he just waited at
the PO box and then some Indian dude
came to pick it up and not they're not
always Indian too they could be like at
a guy at an Airbnb just waiting and then
so they employed they Outsourcing
different steps yeah and then some guy
would just be there to pick up a package
and then he'll he would he wouldn't open
up the package he's just waiting at the
Airbnb to to pretend like uh like FedEx
is here okay and then he gets it and
then he goes and then he sends it to
India wow yeah you know what's really
funny too is that like if you go to any
American Business where an Indian guy
works he definitely has an Indian name
but then these guys all [__] American
names
with the Microsoft store I am Timmy I'm
like you're not [__] like why can't
you just have an Indian name yeah yeah
it's normal to have an idiot yeah they
think they're getting away with it yeah
yeah but like he's buying it he's buying
it
has Indian names but like as if it's
more trustworthy that he is named
Timothy yeah yeah and you go oh
wow so I oh Microsoft money I need to
pay them with gift cards
right like he's Timmy and then we got a
guy here who sounds wider than us named
ritesh yeah yeah dude it's like sure
he's he's the voice that can for God's
sakes named dude my mom's neighbor she
got she got popped with the um like a
water bill one where it's like you have
to pay your water bill but you have to
go to like a Bitcoin station to pay for
it and and she and then and bro this is
WP is like you got to pay with Bitcoin
they're like we're gonna [__] cut off
your water if you don't do this and she
this lady's like talking to my mom like
can you take me can you take me I have
to go and my mom was like please don't
do this I don't think this is like legit
and then she takes her the whole time
and the lady their neighbor tells my mom
like shut up you don't know what you're
talking about
as you've paid like like a thousand
dollars to this Bitcoin my grandpa
almost got scammed like the scam was
about how I was in like jail or prison
or something and that I needed money for
bail and
um you know that you know I reached out
and I couldn't get a hold of them and
needed to send money and I mean he was
smart enough to call my mom and be like
where is she
the funny things he didn't question you
being in jail no but it was like
straight up that was more plausible than
anything he was like Colleen's in jail
but like she doesn't need bails yeah
this is not the first time yeah she's
gonna be okay yeah she deserves this one
yeah how much does bail was too much I
had a buddy reach out to me on Facebook
and I hadn't talked to the guy in like a
decade and he's like hey Steve I'm like
trapped in [__] South Korea or
whatever and like I my money's not
working my Travelers checks got stolen
can you wire me like 200 bucks or some
[__] and then I was like I don't think
this is you and they killed him
kill him set music
what's in the box
[Music]